the installation of a floating border
wall in the Rio Grande Valley is
expected to be finished this weekend the
1 000 foot long Marine barrier will
stretch to the length of about three
football fields which means Texas
officials say it's a way to prevent
migrants from making the potentially
deadly swim across the river in the
Eagle Pass area here its reaction is
retired acting ice director and Fox News
contributor Tom home and Tom good
morning to you good morning Hey listen
we've tried all sorts of things down
there maybe this will work
I think it'll have an impact look
Governor I have a hats off to him he's
done more to secure this border than
this Administration has I mean the
Administration has advocated their
responsibilities the governor Abbott's
doing everything he can not to not just
to protect Texas but mostly migrants are
staying in Texas it protects the entire
country and he's going to save lives by
doing this because family groups are not
going to try to come across that current
in the river and have an obstacle they
still got to get over this is going to
save lives so hats off to Governor
Abbott well it doesn't look very deep
right there because we just saw it looks
like a piece of heavy equipment I I
don't know if it's on pontoons or if it
is on the bottom but yeah that's just on
the bottom so it's only a couple of feet
deep there but it's not that big what
about a foot of the buoy is underwater
and about three four feet or above is
that's enough to slow people down right
it isn't absolve people down but it's it
you can't really tell by the look at the
picture of the river the current is what
the problem is that once the migrants
get in the current the current is very
strong even border patrol agents have to
have trouble in that River so it's not
so much the depth of the water is the
current in the river that it takes so
many lives all right uh listen let's
talk a little bit about a Premiere you
were at the the premiere of an episode
of defend the Border it was called Death
County and the river of Broken Dreams
we're gonna play just a little bit of it
so people know what we're talking about
watch this
this is a real brand under President
Biden has turned into a river of Broken
Dreams we don't know if they are the
parents to these children or not right
usually they'll use them because they
think that they'll get an easier access
into the country wherein at this point
all you have to do is walk up there's
nothing made up about the Border crisis
we're getting attacked every single day
nobody understands that this happens
several times a day
uh you know what for a lot of people who
are not caught up on the border and a
lot of people who do know a lot there's
a lot of stuff in here that is very
interesting
yeah we you know I wrote a book when I
retired called defend the border and
save lives and this documentary is based
on my experiences and you know 34 years
and the tragedies that I've been
involved with we talked to this network
several times about some of the criminal
investigations I ran the tragedies were
you know 17 migrants you know eight 19
migrants suffocated death and tractor
Trail including a five-year-old boy I'm
talking to girls as young as nine years
old it's been raped multiple times by
the criminal cartels so I wrote the book
trying to explain to American people
look regardless of what your opinion is
on illegal immigration when you cause a
crisis this big it's a record number of
women and children been sex trafficking
in this country under this
Administration a record number of
non-suspected terrorists have been
arrested entered this country this
Administration a record amount of
fentanyls come in this country under
this Administration more Americans are
dead under fentanyl historic record more
migrants have died on entering this
country over 1700 which is a record so
you know I want to explain to American
people it's just not about border
security it's about saving lives if we
defend the border and secure the board
order you save lives and the great thing
about this documentary series that
you've put together is it's absolutely
free all you got to do is go to
defendtheborder.org and then you can
watch them there are eight different
episodes look at that Tom you're now a
film producer a documentary producer a
documentary guy that hasn't made a dime
I haven't made a dime in this I won't
make a dime on this this is about
educating American people on the border
so when they get to the bowling booth
next year they vote for the person who's
going to secure that border all right
sir thank you very much for joining us
live looks great thanks for having me
thanks Tom I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis